yeah about 200 pages into something new
you know what it's this novel I've been
trying to write for 25 years about this
little little chunk of my life that had
to do with the 70s and poverty and sex
drugs and rock and roll really and I
think I think I've come to the
conclusion that i'm not i'm not one of
these writers who can write fiction
derivatively from my life directly I
can't have a bad thanksgiving in texas
and write a short story with bad
thanksgiving in texas Truman Capote
could you know hidden we had his Nick
Adams stories a lot of writers can but a
lot of writers can't and I think I'm in
the camp that can't so I think it's
creative nonfiction memoir
I've also i'm also working on
collections of novellas two are done and
i hope that i'll be working on that next
so the next two books hopefully would be
this collection of creative nonfiction /
memoir in a collection of novellas but i
have to say man that I'm really you know
a friend of mine has a garage band rock
and roll garage band and he prefers to
listen to rock and roll garage bands and
I and I prefer to read novels even
though I love the short story and I read
a lot of poetry so I prefer to write
novels and but I think that's really
more my temperament I really like
getting lost in a four five six hundred
page story over three or four years of
my life I really it's like it's like a
big mural on the side of a building I
really like how big the novel is not my
novel but D novel so but i would say no
I would try not to say no to any kind of
right I think writers should try all
kinds
yeah I'm not as particularly interested
in green plays only i'll tell you why
though and not that i don't respect them
you know some are really quite artful
i'm thinking of horton foote or paul
schrader there's some really good
screenwriters but for me I'm lost
without the central detail back to that
Carlson line if you know I can't just
have exterior shot Walmart and then
start having people talking them I need
to feel the is it a hot sunny day in
that parking lot Walmart does he smell
urine on the asphalt which reminds me of
his uncle which makes him call his aunt
which makes you see don't say it steers
the action so I'm actually lost in the
play and screenplay forms because they
don't have enough one of my favorite
American poets these days been reading a
lot of is steven dunn wonderful poet I
love Sharon olds been ramki Maria how
Carolyn forshay so many good ones I read
a lot of poetry I've been reading Gerald
Stern and I mean reading such as low
Milosz it i've been very intrigued with
his latest book because he's really
wrestling with his Catholic faith he's
really wrestling with the notion of
faith which I'm I'm resting
you